your mom has sex she's a grown-up human
being did you know that yeah what she
was she sounds dildos
[Applause]
why did it become about you do you sell
dildos are you a door-to-door dildo
sales person
it's like Tupperware except that goes
into your in your vagina yeah
yeah
Tupperware I'm buying that
if I can put my leftovers in a dildo
shape Tupperware and put that
if I could let me tell you something
right now if I can put my meat in my
meat are you kidding me right now
oh my God that is not a terrible idea uh
okay so let me ask you a couple more
questions
by the way if anybody has any questions
for her please raise your hand I'm happy
to it seems like more like a group thing
but
is there a Best Seller yes what would
that who said yes over there
over there yes
[Music]
your clients are back there
am I out of me
dude I didn't know I came to the dildo
club for
so you're close by the way
you mean the people who buy dildos from
you
is that is it look like it's two couples
yeah no no just four separate people who
might dildos
everybody has sex no I'm with you I'm
with you
I had never thought of this but coven
was probably great for the dildo
business
welcome
some people bake bread you know
now are you pre-covered dildo users or
just
or post coven is this what tell me
yes to which I answered two questions
[Music]
you were pre-covered dildo and dude you
too
don't judge me dude 2023 you know what I
mean get your Tupperware dildo
um so were you uh all four of you are
separate dildo users
oh they're a couple
that's your daughter
so your daughter that's your your wife
your girlfriend next to you dude this is
my wife your wife
this is your daughter and so who
I can't swim hold on one second
you don't get to chime in yet okay
who introduced who what's your name
who introduced this course it is who
introduced who to Vicky who was Vicky's
first client my wife you're right yeah
yeah dude I gotta tell you and so
he what
is it oh my gosh okay so then your wife
and then what's the daughter's name
so how did you get involved with Vicky
did your mom tell you like hey
Merry Christmas
this is for my friend Vicky
well how did that
so Vicky um can you tell by the order
you're like this is definitely mom and
how many times do people have to client
infers repeat customers how many
different dildos like how hard are you
riding them where you need to be like I
need a new one I need a new one
how do they work
I know
you can't wash a dildo
[Music]
no
she just asked if I wanted with my
dishes no but but I mean to be honestly
no
wow and so and um and so you go and go
to people's houses you like have Trump
cards that's uh no pun intended but yeah
yeah okay
all right okay and so MIA
[Music]
when how old were you when you learned
that your mom sold dildos
12.
wow did you ever bring her into Show and
Tell at school
what does your mom do oh I'm gonna bring
her in tomorrow
this will be the last day for me in this
class
okay
all right guys the
um show and tell part of the show is
over
uh that was amazing thank you so much
Vicky thank you very much I'll see you
in the meet and greet
um okay and I think somebody means a
50th birthday dildo
smoke weed bring it
bring it
[Applause]
[Music]